die frage was ist der mensch ist heute
sehr dehnbar dank fitness programmen
vitamintabletten und
schönheitsoperationen werden wir
körperlich immer perfekter doch ist
perfekt in jeder hinsicht auch besser
nein sagt dezidiert jürgen liebig er
moderiert im westdeutschen rundfunk die
sendung das philosophische radio und ist
auch erfolgreicher buchautor bibi
gefordert dass wir so bleiben wie wir
sind
denn letztlich ging es im leben auch
darum uns mit der vergänglichkeit und
dem zerfall anzufreunden
aber blödsinn fortschritt skeptiker
eingeladen um mit ihm über das bessere
leben zu philosophieren
irgendwie bekämpft sie haben ein buch
geschrieben gegen die perfektionierung
orten sobald ich selber kein
verbesserungspotenzial
doch täglich tag ich bin jeden tag von
dem geist getrieben wie kann ich noch
ein bisschen besser werden
wie kann ich auch fitter werden bei
sport in meinem leben eine große rolle
spielt also es ist jetzt nicht so dass
sich der wahlbürger binde sagt alles
muss so bleiben wie es ist
obwohl da steht als titel des buches
dürfen wir so bleiben wie sie sind und
wir dürfen ihr zu glauben wie wir sind
und unten dran steht es geht gegen die
perfektionierung des menschen ja das ist
interessant wenn ich jetzt eine lesung
mache und die leute kommen hinterher zu
mir und sagen ja sie werden doch
hoffentlich in ihrem buch sagen ja wir
dürfen zu bleiben wie wir sind
und dann
weise ich auf das fragezeichen hin und
gebe auch schon mal ein hinweis darauf
dass ist das eigentlich eine rhetorische
frage ist denn natürlich werden menschen
nicht so bleiben wie wir sind denn wenn
das unsere einstellung wäre dann würden
wir ja immer noch irgendwo in afrika auf
den bäumen hat genau irgendwie müssen
wir ja wachsen das ist auch so ein
menschliches bedürfnis dass die uns
weiterentwickeln gegen einen horizont in
peter sloterdijk hat an diesem
wunderschönen buch du musst dein leben
ändern
von so einer vertikal spannung
gesprochen dass wir immer nach oben
gucken und uns irgendwie strecken wollen
was es aus dem bild dass ihnen ihr
entgegenkommt ja und ich finde auch bei
den vielen begriffen dies lutterberg
erfindet und die man oft nicht versteht
hänge ich doch sehr an diesem wort
vertikal spannung weil das glaube ich
sehr gut beschreibt was unser bestreben
es wir wollen eben wir wollen nach oben
wir wollen uns transzendieren wir wollen
das möglichst aus uns machen und wenn
wir das nicht tun dann versagten wären
dann in der mittelmäßigkeit also in
diesem geist hängig auch drin aber ich
glaube es macht einen unterschied ob man
an seine talente anknüpft
ob man trainiert ob man an etwas
entwickelt ich möchte das beste aus
meinen begabungen machen oder ob man
sagt begabungen und talente hin oder her
ich mache das mit künstlichen methoden
ich verändere meine natur und da sitzen
für mich schwierig genau da sind sie ja
eher dagegen sprechen wir darüber
späteren beginnen wir noch einmal bei
der frage wie viel fitness soll
eigentlich sein wie sie sollen ja
unseren talenten arbeiten da sagen sie
jetzt hausen sind sie durchaus offen
sind das ist eine gute sache wir sollen
uns bemühen und das beste aus uns
herausholen
warum nervt uns denn eigentlich das
sogenannte perfektionist wir müssten mal
damit ich damit wir nicht über das
falsche miteinander sprechen sagen was
sie dafür einen wesenszug malen
aktionisten ja das weiß ich gar nicht so
recht ehrlich gesagt aber es ist doch so
man spricht man über leuten sagen wir es
so perfektionistisch
ich weiß nicht machen vielleicht eine
gewisse dringlichkeit ja na gut dagegen
sind wir wahrscheinlich deswegen weil
wir sagen mensch perfektionist warum
kommst du nicht damit klar dass es auch
unfertiges an uns gibt das ist dass das
ist das scheitern gibt dass es die
schwäche gibt und ich glaube das ist
auch das was mich am meisten umtreibt
also zu schauen ist der perfektionist
eigentlich das leid modell nicht nur für
den einzelnen sondern für eine ganze
gesellschaft sind wir dabei eine
gesellschaft zu bauen
in der das unperfekte das labile das
schwache das kranke eigentlich gar kein
platz mehr
und da habe ich jetzt weil ich glaube
dass ist doch eigentlich schon so ein
bisschen die these die sich durchzieht
durch ihr buch was sie schon ein
bisschen befürchten dass wir alle in so
eine maschinerie geraten wir bauen
besser werden müssen ganz genau
also versuchen wir diese diese idee noch
ein bisschen zu vertiefen wo hakt es
denn genau was finden sie problematisch
ich glaube also dieses buch handelt von
sehr verschiedenen bioethischen
baustellen und wir haben im moment die
tendenz jede ethische frage in diesem
bereich für sich zu behandeln
nehmen sie pd also die frage ob man
künstlich produzierte embryonen bevor
sie in den mutterleib eingepflanzt
werden ob man die einmal durchs kennt
nach bestimmten perfekten oder nicht
verboten ist die pd die wir die hier
vermutlich ziemlich bald abstimmen
werden wir sprechen bundesverfassungs
artikel der das jetzt verbietet ja ja
und in deutschland es gibt es ja auch
eine sprunghafte entwickeln wir hatten
bislang auch das verbot aber es gab nach
langer debatte eine knappe abstimmung im
bundestag die gesagt hat in sehr engen
grenzen wollen wir die pd zu lassen aber
egal
es ist ein beispiel dann gibt es am
anderen ende des lebens also alle
probleme am anfang des lebens grund am
ende des lebens berühren sich meiner
meinung nach in dem punkt ob wir dabei
sind ein bild vom menschen zu zeichnen
das ja eben den perfekten mensch als
ideal nimmt also kurz gesagt
interveniere ich dagegen dass man dass
wir dabei sind zu sagen entweder bin ich
fit oder ich bin tot
wenn wir nochmal peter sloterdijk nehmen
der sagt ja menschen die so bleiben
wollen wie sie sind sind eigentlich die
sogenannten finalen spießer diese
spießigkeit können sie dieser idee etwas
abgewinnen sie es ganz gut mal wenn sie
nach spießer zu sein
auch in bestimmten lebenssituationen ist
es vielleicht auch ganz gut mal spießer
zu sein wenn das bedeutet dass man pause
macht dass man kraft schöpft dass man
überlegt wie ist eigentlich meine
stellung im hamsterrad der permanenten
veränderung aber im prinzip wie gesagt
beginnt eigentlich die
menschheitsgeschichte damit dass wir uns
auf den weg gemacht haben und diese
wickelt natürlich niemals auf also
menschen werden sich verändern
das sind nochmal bei ihrem buch dürfen
wir so bleiben wie wir sind und da gibt
es dieses koffer da haben die ja
eigentlich die menschheitsgeschichte ein
bisschen auf gebildet die berühmte
bilder reihe von der menschwerdung des
affen genau die ja hier bei ihnen
vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
endet nicht beim anlassen schilder
superman ist was es bringt also wir
haben überlegt wie können wir eigentlich
ein bild dafür geben warum es in diesem
buch eigentlich geht und mein vorschlag
war zu überlegen wo kommen wir her und
was in welcher weise sind wir eigentlich
gerade dabei am menschen der zukunft zu
bauen
und wir haben den für uns das steht da
natürlich nicht drin
den brennern genannt weil das ist ja so
eine super man figur die extrem elan in
bewegung ist die vor kraft eigentlich
kaum sprinten kann und auf der brust das
soll eben ein hirn sein weil sie
natürlich wissen dass heute viele
diskurse um optimierung sich darum
drehen wie wir hier all das was unter
unserem schädel ist möglichst schonend
und optimieren können und das war für
mich ein zeichen um zu sagen ja dass das
ist mein thema und wenn wir bei dieser
rate bleiben ist dass sie sich ein graus
2003 einmal zu landen
also ich habe noch niemanden erlebt für
den das kein großes
das ist ja das merkwürdige die meisten
menschen sagen um gottes willen will ich
niemals sein diese supermann figur
das strebe ich gar nicht an ich möchte
das ist dass das ist diese sehnsucht von
der ich gerade erzählt habe ich möchte
dass die frage dürfen wir so bleiben wie
wir sind möglichst mit ja beantwortet
wird
obwohl sie am anfang gesagt haben dass
seine ironische frage ja beides wir
haben halt beides in uns drin und zwar
von beginn an
wir wollen uns perfektionieren
verbessern perfekte bild esa ein
berühmter begriff auch von rousseau ja
und gleichzeitig möchten wir aber auch
in die ruhe kommen also wenn sie sich
anschauen
worum sich philosophie auch gerade im
mittelalter gedreht hat ja ist das dass
der mensch eigentlich ganz bei sich ist
wenn er eben aus dem getümmel aus der
permanenten beschleunigung rausgeht und
in die rohre kommen
das sind diese beiden pole ich würde
diese in die ruhe kommen und diesen
schönen sucht sich auch nicht dauernd
gegen den treffen zu müssen dafür steht
ja ein anderer autor der fast so wie das
gegenbild ist peter sloterdijk nämlich
der aller ehrenberg das buch das
erschöpfte selbst der soziologe der
französische soziologe hat er untersucht
warum es eigentlich heute so viele
depressionen gibt und seine idee
dahinter ist früher hatten wir die
neurosen die eigentlich als
krankheitsbild dafür stehen was sich das
in die
abgrenzen muss dauernd von dieser
gesellschaft die ihn irgendwas ausdrückt
und als man das gefühl eine zwangs
gesellschaft und jetzt sind in einer
freiheits gesellschaft und das
überfordert und denken sie das ist so
etwas wo man sagt ich möchte gerne so
bleiben wie ich bin und ich möchte mich
hier jetzt nicht dauernd neu entscheiden
was ich auch noch werden könnte
naja bei ehrenberg geht es ja nicht
darum zu sagen dass dieser weg heraus
aus der zwangs gesellschaft aus der
gesellschaft der neurose die in der der
einzelne sich immer die frage stellen
musste was darf ich und was darf ich
nicht also dieses umstellt seien von
verboten da sagte ehrenberg nicht wir
müssen dahin zurück sondern im gegenteil
ist es ja gut dass wir das hinter uns
haben
er weist aber sehr frühzeitig daraufhin
worin eigentlich mögliche pathologien
liegen wenn die zwänge weg sind und dann
nicht das reich der freiheit ausbricht
sondern plötzlich bestimmte zwänge
verinnerlicht werden und ich glaube das
ist etwas wo er sehr scharfsinnig und
früh darauf hingewiesen hat dass das
gerade die die vielen menschen die
momentan in die depression in
eingewandert sind im prinzip diese
soziale krankheit durch leben das sie
dass sie darunter leiden möglichst viel
aus sich machen zu müssen also das ist
ein selbst auferlegter zwang ist in der
freien gesellschaft zu sagen
nun muss ich aber auch was aus der
freiheit machen und wenn ich scheitere
wenn ich nicht zu den siegern gehöre
dann bin ich selber schuld
also die alte schuldfrage ja die machen
wir nur mit uns selber ab und und plagen
uns daran und werden darüber kann
das sind ja fast schon wieder bei sagte
sie dass die freiheit eigentlich ein
stück weit eine geisel ist wir bauern
werden müssen
vielleicht müssen wir vielleicht ist das
ein durchgangsstadium also so lange sind
wir noch nicht frei überhaupt es ist ja
eine starke these zu sagen wir sind frei
aber jedenfalls freiheit muss
wahrscheinlich auch wie ein muskel
trainiert werden müssen ist ein üben
ich habe diesen stock mit gebrochenen
stock sprechen
gerne komme wie sie sagten ja es wäre
ganz schön mal zu überlegen ob es einen
gegenstand gibt und dem man etwas zeigen
kann was mir wichtig ist ich lange
überlegt was es sein könnte
bin im keller rung gestiefelt und traf
dann auf einen angeknacksten wanderstab
und also das ist sozusagen das obere
ende eines selbstgemachten wanderstab es
uns nicht nehmen sollen und erinnert
mich an eine unglaublich strapaziöse
tour in den alpen von hütte zu hütte
eine woche mit härtester anstrengung und
großem glück
das ist also mal das eine was man an
diesem stück zeigen kann diese vertikal
spannung dann bestimmte schweißen tränen
ja oft wirklich ganz genau und für die
also für das glück der anstrengung
eigentlich kann man sich ja die frage
stellen wieso muten wir uns das
freiwillig zu 600 meter aufstieg und
dann schweißnass einmal oben zu stehen
dann pfeift einem auch noch der wind
entgegen und es ist wird schnell
ungemütlich aber das glück besteht in
der anstrengung und wir müssen heute
überlegen ob es ob es versprechungen
gibt dass man das glück ohne anstrengung
brücke bekommt da bin ich sehr skeptisch
aber habe ich das gefühl es geht sowie
unterschiedliche sphären dass man
beispielsweise mit sportlicher
anstrengung zu mehr glück kommt ich
glaube dass würden doch sehr viele leute
teilen gucken die nur mal an die die
raten gestiegenen zehn personen die
marathonläufer geworden sind jeder ging
heute in marathon laufen
ich mache ein halbmarathon auf dem weg
dazu
wenn das team auch wenn sie hier sind
sind sie wahrscheinlich auch mache
aufgegangen nein nein auf gar kein
schweizer vater strecke stecken bleiben
nein ich bleibe überhaupt nicht stecken
sondern ich merke man eine sache mir gut
tut wenn sie mich glücklich macht wenn
sie mich voranbringt und wann es auch
ein zuviel gibt aber worauf ich
eigentlich hinaus baut ist dass ich
sagen würde es gibt vielleicht eben
dimensionen da sind die leute durchaus
bereit sich sehr anzustrengen weil sie
eben genau wissen dass da drüben dann
auf dem gipfel das schöne glück wirkt
die idee dass man etwas wirklich besiegt
hat ein gipfel erklommen haben aber in
vielen anderen bereichen des lebens habe
ich manchmal das gefühl ist es wirklich
so dass wir so gerne an die grenzen
gehen ich habe aber das gefühl gedimmt
und bissen in der komfortzone herum wenn
es zb darum geht verantwortung zu
übernehmen
also man muss ja jetzt um bei der alpen
wanderung zu bleiben man muss natürlich
auch schauen was die grenzen wirklich
sind und ich bin kein spieler
ich muss jetzt nicht da klettern und
mein leben riskieren
aber das ist auch für mich nur eine
deutung dieses dieses stocks also dass
er mich eben an einen an das glück der
anstrengung erinnert eine zweite wäre zu
überlegen ja sind wir beide eigentlich
auch so wie diese stock also sind wir
natur oder ist der mensch was ganz
anderes
na ja ich glaube wir sind komplett
anders als der stock also im sturm
stellt sie endlich die frage natürlich
das nichtwissen nicht sie sind natürlich
habe ich schon sagen ich würde sagen wir
kommen aus natur aber genau das was wir
jetzt besprochen haben läuft nicht
darauf hinaus zusagen zu und jetzt wird
es ein bisschen paradox aber zu unserer
natur gehört dass wir unsere natur
permanent verändern
das ist richtig dass ich dieser stock ja
aber auch der ist nämlich geschnitzt
aber von menschen richtig da hat sich
nicht selber geschützt aber die frage
wäre ja dann auch noch was ist
eigentlich der gegenpart zur natur
meistens hat man ja so eine idee die
natur auf der anderen seite
künstlichkeit
ich bin kein künstliches wesen aber wir
können auch kulturell geformt ja gut
aber sie wissen selber und davon handelt
dieses buch zum teil
dass es momentan halt sehr viele
verheißungen und visionen gibt die sagen
wir sind an einem schnittpunkt unserer
menschheitsgeschichte
wir verlassen sozusagen den raum unserer
natürlichen grundlagen und schaffen uns
eine zweite eine künstliche evolution
mit technischen oder mit
pharmazeutischen mitteln genau das sind
die bei der zweiten idee der
perfektionierung des menschen also nicht
training arbeitern sich selber vertikal
spannung im sinne von sloterdijk dass
man sich weiterentwickelt auch im
hinblick auf ziele die man sich steckt
sondern eben die technisch medizinische
verbesserung des menschen stichwort in
händen
das werden sie keine gute sache also ich
würde es nicht machen
[Musik]
erzählen sie mal entschuldigung
entziehen sie war von anna aber ist ja
so eine figur die kommt vorher hoch was
macht die anna anna hat eine
vorgeschichte
es gibt ein memorandum das ist vor
einigen jahren erschien in einer
zeitschrift die heißt gehirn und geist
haben sich einige bioethiker
zusammengetan und haben eine geschichte
von anna erzählt dieses memorandum heißt
das optimierte gehirn und anna das ist
die fallgeschichte kommt in die
situation hinein dass der tag der
hochzeit ihrer besten freundin ist und
sie wacht sie beginnt den tag mit einem
furchtbaren streit mit ihrem partner und
ist eigentlich völlig unfähig ihre rolle
an diesem hochzeitstag für ihre beste
freundin auszufüllen sie ist süß
vieles menschen sie ist die trauzeugen
pippa po ja jedenfalls sie stürzt
bedingt durch dieses durch diese
trennung in eine depression hinein und
nun stellt sich heraus dass in ihrer
wohngemeinschaft jemand der ohnehin an
depressionen leidet eine kleine capital
hat und dann sagt joana du könntest du
auch diese happy pillen nehmen die hilft
dir aus diesem tal hinaus du kannst
alles tun was vorgesehen ist und
außerdem ist sie fast frei von
nebenwirkungen und dann stellen eben
diese bioethiker die rhetorische frage
was spricht denn eigentlich dagegen dass
anna diese pille einwirft sich neuronal
für diese paar stunden optimiert und
damit die hochzeit rettet genau würden
wir beide sagen mach doch genau erstmal
auch erst mal wo liegt der unterschied
dazu wenn man in die kräne hat ein
schmerzen sind zu nehmen gut aber jetzt
weiter sie sagen erst mal wo liegt das
problem
ja ich habe lange überlegt was gefällt
mir an diesem beispiel nicht dann habe
ich gedacht wenn wir heute über über die
situation von menschen reden die
versuchen besser zu funktionieren
dann geschieht das doch nichts beim
hochzeitstag der besten freundin sondern
die musik spielt ganz woanders dieses
beispiel ist in falschen theater
angesiedelt wir müssen in die
arbeitswelt schauen um zu gucken warum
bereits heute leistungssteigernde
präparate eingeworfen werden damit man
im beruf eine gute performance abgibt
und insofern gefällt mir das ganze
szenario nicht und deswegen würde ich
gerne aus der anna die eine gute party
schmeißen soll und damit ihre pflichten
als freundin erfüllt eine büro existenz
machen die sich
kapitalistischen konkurrenzkampf
behaupten muss hmm
dh wir haben jetzt eine amadé ist zb
meinem büro nachbarin und die sofort
besser wie man heutzutage sagt genau
also die ist schneller fitter die
erledigt mehr und so weiter und die
nimmt eine pille jeden morgen
und jetzt hat sich ihr wert urteil
offenbar vereinbart ja meine vorstellung
ist dass diese anna weil sie eben im
verborgenen diese happy pills nimmt die
ihre kognitiven fähigkeiten verbessern
soll
performerinnen des monats wird also sie
denken kreist sie kriegt ein preis sie
sagt auch ihre nachbarin am anderen
schreibtisch ich brauche auch gar nicht
mehr so viel schlafen ich kann mehr
leisten und den nachbarin guckt zu und
denkt wie kann das denn sein diese an
einer die hat sich völlig verändert
und plötzlich stellt sie dann fest auch
hier in den papierkorb legte eine
packung und sie sich dann happy pills
eingeworfen und dann ist die frage was
passiert eigentlich zwischen den beiden
und bei diesem ganzen diskussionen um
ein hands nennt ich glaube wir müssen
das wort ein bisschen erklären to
enhance heißt ja sich verbessern
in diesem huntsman diskussionen um die
frage ob man eben pillen einwerfen darf
die ein kluger und
konzentrationsfähigkeit und
leistungsfähiger machen
da geht es häufig darum darf man das aus
gerechtigkeitsgründen da würden wir
glaube ich sagen ist dass das
hauptproblem also gerechtigkeitsgründen
wäre zum beispiel so etwas wie der
wettbewerb ist uns da wir haben doch der
vergleich zum doping genau da stehen
zwei sprinter am start der eine hat sich
gedopt der andere nicht dann ist das
resultat des wettbewerbs des sprints ist
ungerecht weil der eine eben bessere
startchancen hc gut aber jetzt in der
arbeitswelt kann man ja sagen da geht es
nicht um sprinten in einem gewissen
hinsicht auch aber nehmen wir mal ihre
welt sie sind radiomoderator ein sehr
erfolgreicher sogar sie moderieren
dieses philosophische radio auf wdr 5
jede woche immer am freitagabend sie
haben 100 tausend zuhörer ungefähr dann
kommen ganz viele podcast downloads dazu
aber es ist ja eher fertig aber gerade
sagen
nehmen wir mal an sie haben einen
kollegen der ist lange zeit mit ihnen
unterwegs letzten sich immer ob
irgendwann stellt sich heraus sie haben
einfach die besseren nerven herr becker
sie kriegen die sendung alleine und ihr
bleibt außen vor
er möchte aber auch wieder mitmachen und
eigentlich kann ja nichts dafür dass er
ein bisschen die schwache nerven hat
aussieht haben also nimmt der happy
pills nennen wir es mal so
man könnte ja auch von ritalin sprechen
bei erwachsenen beispielsweise ritalin
zur konzentrationssteigerung bei
erwachsenen
plötzlich ist er würdig genau also jetzt
könnte man auch sagen ungerecht ist auch
eigentlich dass sie angeborener weisen
die besseren nerven haben
nicht dass er immer das ist natürlich
eine sehr raffinierte dort und vorplatz
vor dass wir durch die existenz von
happy pills eine art paradiesischen
kommunismus krieg ich wollte sagen
gewisse in helsa gewisse medikamente
oder es ist da viel ist noch
zukunftsmusik auch wenn man mal das
gedankenexperiment weiterspinnt gewisse
mitteln die uns verbessern könnten
könnten ja auch dazu dienen angeborene
chancenungleichheit auszugleichen
glauben sie daran ich habe ich glaube
zumindest daran dass wir zu sehr so tun
als wäre alles was sie erreichen ständig
selbst zuzuschreiben ich glaube wir
haben einfach unglaublich ungleiche
stadt bitten ganz genau
und da wissen wir noch einmal
zurückkommen auf die analogie zum sport
wenn da acht starter sind beim 100 meter
lauf dann geht es um chancengleichheit
sie sollen alle am punkt null beginnen
genau wovon gleichen schuhe haben von
mir aus oder zumindest ähnliche material
zur verfügung natürlich aber wir wissen
ganz genau wie bei
wir könnten trainieren ohne ende und
trotzdem würden wir niemals in einem
finale landen weil nämlich die
begabungen und talente einfach nicht
gleich verteilt werden und die
vorstellung wir wollten das kompensieren
na ja das geht aber wirklich nur mit der
verheißung dass wir neuen menschen bauen
und doppelt sinn für mich ungemütlich
ich glaube wenn wir eine erfahrung
gemacht haben im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
dann ist es die dass wir aufpassen
müssen die neuen menschen bauen zu
wollen
das geht furchtbar in die hose und ist
gerechtigkeit herzustellen überfordert
sie da wird mir schwindelig ich wollte
vielleicht eher darauf hinaus zu sagen
dann ist es nicht ein bisschen das
privileg derjenigen die erfolgreich sind
gegen in handys zu reden weil die kann
ja gut reden
ich habe nämlich natürlicherweise die
talent in die wiege gelegt
also ich kann noch mal auf dieses
memorandum zu sprechen ja einen bioethik
an die ihr im prinzip dafür plädiert
haben dass man das verbot verbietet also
dass wir uns vorurteilsfrei solchen
dingen nähern sollten
und wenn es das gibt dann sollten wir
eher auf die chancen also auf die
risiken schauen und dann sagen die allen
ernstes
man könnte doch tatsächlich das geistige
niveau heben eine gesellschaft wenn man
nämlich den schwachen solche
möglichkeiten eröffnet diese pillen ein
zu werfen und sie bauen eine analogie
und sagen ja es gibt doch sowieso
ungleich halten die einen bekommen eine
teure ausbildung auf einer privatschule
oder auf einer privaten universität und
die anderen eben nicht und könnten wir
dadurch nicht gerechtigkeit herstellen
da sind sehr skeptisch da bin ich
allerdings skeptisch
weil ich es wackelt sich finde diese
analogie durchzuhalten
denn wir haben anfangs darüber
gesprochen sie haben den sloterdijk
hervorgezogen und werden über das üben
über das trainieren über diesen etwas
gesprochen sich nicht so schnell mit
sich selbst zufrieden zu geben sondern
sich entwickeln zu wollen und das ist
die bildungsgeschichte ist es amtlich
genau aber das sind wir ja hier noch
einen ganz anderen punkt glaube ich dass
es für mich wie ein anderes argument zu
sagen wir wollen auch dinge schaffen die
jungs zu schreiben können also ich
möchte nicht mit dem taxi auf dem gipfel
hoch sondern ich möchte da hoch
marschiert im schweiße seines angesichts
weil ich nachher sagen möchte ich habe
das geschafft genau
und genau so ist es wahrscheinlich auch
mit leistungen im berufsleben man ist
natürlich sehr viel mehr stolz darauf
wenn man es sich selber zu schreiben
kann was könnte wahrscheinlich ein
zusätzliches argument sein gegen im
herzen ja aber wissen sie auch der
abbruch auch das scheitern gehört zu
unserem selbstkonzept und vielen
menschen geht es so dass sie
im nachhinein oft sehr glücklich sind
dass mal was schief gegangen also ich
möchte nicht sie versuchten mir gerade
irgendwie zuzuschieben nur die nur die
erfolgreichen lehnen so etwas ab weil
sie den blick dafür verlieren das sie
mit talenten irgendwie gesegnet sind die
nicht jeder hat aber ich glaube gerade
umgekehrt dass wir einen blick dafür
bekommen müssen wie das nicht gelingen
und das scheitern wie die schwäche uns
stark machen kann also dem mal ganz das
banalste dürfen wir auf keinen fall
vergessen
bei diesen diskussionen und happy pills
es gibt diese pillen nicht und sie so zu
behandeln als ob sie sozusagen kurz vor
der marktreife wäre ist schlicht gelogen
im moment ich finde wir sollten schon
beispiele suchen aus dem raum leben und
das in der schweiz zumindest gibt schon
eine große debatte zum beispiel bei
ritalin
also man weiß dass medizinstudierende
bei ihren prüfungen es gibt natürlich da
ganz viele dunkelziffern man ist sich
nicht so ganz sicher bin sondern trauen
aber man geht davon aus dass rund 15
prozent von der medizinstudierenden
italien nehmen und wir wissen ja ritalin
ist bei kindern die sehr unruhig sind
die schwierigkeiten haben sich
konzentrieren ist das kein händler
sondern dass es einen ein therapeutikum
es ist ein medikament zur behandlung
einer krankheit bei erwachsenen hingegen
nicht jeder sicher ist ob es diese
krankheit gibt aber nur zur diskussion
hier heute nicht aber bei erwachsenen
ist es ganz klar ein sogenannter in
händler es ist der versuch die
konzentrationsfähigkeit zu steigern weil
und tan zu steigern beispielsweise vor
prüfungen jetzt nehmen wir mal an 15 der
studie nehmen das wirklich und das ist
keine zukunftsmusik das ist real das ist
ja auch eine form von von ihnen
leistungsstarke hätte vielleicht das
haben wir glaube ich verschiedene
argumente gehabt das eine war
gerechtigkeit als sie haben gesagt das
ist ungerecht weil diejenigen die
besseren ergebnisse haben haben sie ja
nicht weil sie sich angestrengt haben
das andere ist die karte trotzdem nicht
die menschen
die in die prüfung gehen unter ritalin
hinterher zur urinprobe bitten
nicht weil ich glaube dass das
gerechtigkeitsproblem nicht dass das
eigentlich ist okay dann richtig da noch
genauer verstehen was ist denn das
eigentliche problem das eigentliche
wollen wissen sie die die die diskussion
sondern das erlauben oder soll man das
verbieten
die interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt nur
am rande
weil wenn man nachdenkt dann dann denkt
man nicht in der rolle des polizisten
oder das riecht das nach sondern in der
ethik geht es um die frage wie wollen
wir eigentlich leben was ist das gute
leben und auch da möchte ich auch etwas
naheliegendes aufmerksam machen wenn
anna im büro existenz von der wir
gesprochen haben meint ihre leistung
steigern zu müssen indem sie diese
pillen einwirft dann wäre doch unsere
erste intuition zu sagen ana ist nah am
see und unsere bürowelt ist so
beschaffen wie wir sie eigentlich nicht
haben wollen
ich glaube das sind ja einen ganz ganz
interessanten punkt sie haben gesagt es
geht doch in der ethik nicht um die
frage was ich eigentlich ein gutes leben
wie wollen wir leben nicht was dürfen
die aber genau was sollen wir verbieten
also anders gesagt es geht eigentlich
darum was ist ein schöner guter stock um
nicht so sehr was darf mit dem stock das
machen zb
interessant daran ist ja was die ganze
moderne it gegangen ist hat schon ross
kann man das sehen sich vor allem noch
mit der frage beschäftigt was dürfen wir
verbieten was ist das richtige in der
gesellschaft was ist das falsche und das
prägt ja eigentlich auch die liberale
gesellschaft die frage was dürfen wir
einander legitimerweise verbieten
genau und irgendwann bleibt nicht mehr
allzu viel übrig was man nicht darf
genauso das ist das mit der freiheit
das wäre was wir besprochen haben ich
glaube man braucht einen hohen
kraftaufwand um heute noch sagen zu
können wir leben in einer
repressiven gesellschaft die die
freiheit räume des einzelnen all zu sehr
beschneidet
ich glaube das problem dieser
philosophie wie sie jetzt beschrieben
haben vor fleisch ist das ist nur die
halbe miete ist
es geht immer nur um die negative
freiheit
es geht um die freiheit als abwehrrecht
gegen über eine möglicherweise
übergriffigen start
ich möchte das dürfen und das dürfen und
dass wir von das dürfen so und wenn man
all diese freiheitsrechte erkämpft hat
was ist denn dann eigentlich ist es dann
ist an das gute leben erfüllt oder väter
was und ich glaube dass wir aufpassen
müssen bei diesem freiheitsbegriff immer
nur das individuum zu sehen dass
einzelne stolze autonome ich ja aber was
wenn man mit menschen unterwegs ist und
spricht und merkt man doch dass
eigentlich die bewegung hin zum duo oder
zum wir eher das problem ist unsere
gesellschaft als dem stolzen ich noch
weitere freiheitsrechte zuzubilligen ich
gebe ihnen völlig recht dass die frage
wie soll ich eigentlich leben was ist
gut für mich vielleicht die wesentliche
frage ist wie sich zu fragen was darf
ich eigentlich alles genommen
aber der grund warum sich tätigen wissen
aus dieser debatte zurückgezogen hat hat
ja eigentlich wesentlich damit zu tun
dass sie in einer pluralistischen
gesellschaft leben es gibt einfach ganz
unterschiedliche lebensentwürfe es gibt
unterschiedliche vorstellungen darüber
was wir gut finden und da hat sich die
philosophische ethik im gegensatz zu
aristoteles zum beispiel noch aber auch
viele spätere autoren
da hat sich die moderne ethik dann
gesagt wir müssen uns neutral verhalten
der staat darf keine vorschriften machen
und das scheinen sie ja auch immer so
ein bisschen zu bedauern sie sagen
öfters in ihrem buch es ist natürlich
nicht mehr möglich in einer
pluralistischen gesellschaft auf
religiöse wertvorstellungen er zurück zu
greifen und zu sagen was wäre eigentlich
das gute für uns
was soll denn die quelle sein dessen
worüber uns verständigen könnten was ist
gutes zusammenleben die quelle kann
eigentlich nur dass urteilsfähige ich
sein und die klugheit besteht für mich
darin zu den immer neuen optionen die
uns eröffnet werden und die unsere
freiheit vermeintlich steigern sollen
zu diesen optionen eben gelegentlich
auch mal nein zu sagen
aber dieses wissen nicht erlaubt oder
verboten damit sind zwischen 11 fertig
aber das spielt für mich nicht die musik
ich glaube dass das es darum geht gut
bescheid zu wissen
er hat deswegen sind für mich diese die
streits die um bestimmte ethische
fragestellungen geführt werden auch
wichtig um die eigene haltung zu
schärfen aber erlaubt oder verboten ist
für mich eigentlich das
uninteressanteste das entscheidende ist
für mich wie entwickle ich eine
möglichkeit um sagen zu können dass eine
es gut für mich und das andere es nicht
gut für mich unabhängig davon ob es ob
es mir jemand erlaubt oder verbietet und
kann das nicht nur jeder für sich selber
entscheiden
ja sie wollen jetzt darauf hinaus was
soll denn der staat machen
nicht nur der staat also ich finde in
allem was sie schreiben sehr interessant
die momente in denen sie auf die
reproduktionsmedizin zu sprechen können
sie sagen an vielen stellen es geht in
die richtung designerbaby oder man nimmt
nicht mehr war das eigentlich dass
zeugen von kindern etwas körperliches
ist dass es damit zu tun habe auch sich
risiken auf eltern sich risiken
auszusetzen weil wir einfach nicht
wissen welches kinder kriegen und das
gehört ganz wesentlich zum eltern seien
dazu und diese ermahnungen aussprechen
die verstehe ich sehr sehr gut aber wie
sie selber fahren
der staat wird diese ermahnungen nicht
aussprechen wird
genauer kann nur verbote oder
erlaubnisse aussprechen also wer soll
diese diese mahnen
figur sozusagen sein in unserer
pluralistischen gesellschaft ich möchte
das an einem beispiel erzählen also wenn
angenommen sie wären jetzt schwanger und
sie würden gebrauch machen von den
möglichkeiten dieser neuen bluttests mit
denen man sehr unspektakulär feststellen
kann ob es das risiko von trisomie 21
gibt dann kann es sehr schnell passieren
dass sie ohne nachzudenken einen
willigen in einem screening nicht nur
trisomie 21 sondern inzwischen in den
usa geht es um 40 merkmale die mit
diesem blut test festgestellt werden
trainer passt in diesen genau so und
dann unversehens landen wir heute in
entscheidungssituationen über über den
fett des lebens ohne dass wir vorher
darüber gut nachgedacht haben und wer
also einmal elternschaft hinter sich
gebracht hat er weiß was das für eine
mühsal ist und das ist für mich
eigentlich ein gutes beispiel um zu
zeigen dass eine klugheit auch im
neinsagen bestehen kann
nur passiert es dann dass man in der
ärztlichen praxis auf unverständnis
stößt wenn man sagt ja die sind diese
pränataldiagnostik darauf verzichten wir
wenn die sagen eine klugheit besteht
auch im neinsagen stimmen absolut zu
aber wir entscheiden uns ja nicht im
luftleeren raum sie wollen wissen wie
man das für allgemeinen kann
ich möchte mir wissen was sind
eigentlich die leitplanken an denen wir
uns orientieren sollen ja sie
argumentieren ja nicht religiös oder
theologisch aber es ist natürlich auch
nicht religiös unmusikalisch das haben
sie natürlich gemerkt
also das ist eine ganz komplizierte
frage das zu beantworten sagen wir mal
so an vier tagen der woche und an den
anderen drei tagen bin ich agnostiker
wer ist der wegweiser also nein wir sind
doch beide heute nicht mehr in der
situation dass wir uns das bieten lassen
würden dass uns jemand reinredet und
sagt das eine darf so und das andere
nicht
aber was glaube ich eine brücke sein
kann
ich glaube es geht darum ein gespür
dafür zu haben und das haben nicht nur
religiöse menschen dass wir uns nicht
nur uns selbst verdanken also dass wir
eben auch nur seiten an uns klar kommen
müssen wir uns nicht gefallen
die wir auch durch noch so viel training
und arbeit an uns selber nicht richtig
kultiviert kriegen und ich glaube das
ist das was mich wirklich interessiert
also diese dieses schwache und
hinfällige seite an uns die gerät immer
mehr aus dem blick und wir sind dabei
uns eine kalte gesellschaft der sieger
zu bauen
wissen sie ich war vorgestern in einem
heim für schwerst pflegebedürftige
menschen wo ich offen sagen musste
anblick solcher menschen ist schwer
auszuhalten und dann sprechen sie mit
dem personal und sie sehen wie
liebevolle pflege mit schwerstkranken
menschen umgehen und den märkten dass
auch in solchen lebenssituationen glück
ist ein über strapaziertes wort aber
eben freude an der eigenen existenz
da ist selbst mit den minimalsten
möglichkeiten und wir heute wir
versuchen uns immer durch das zu
definieren was wir können und möglichst
alle das weg zu arbeiten was wir nicht
können aber unweigerlich laufen wir in
einen zustand hinein wo wir abgeben
müssen und das ist eine form von
klugheit die uns mehr und mehr abhanden
kommt wir können es kaum noch aushalten
solche menschen anzuschauen sie haben ja
sehr viel kontakt zu sagen wir mal
einfach den menschen da draußen sie sind
am mikrofon haben ihre philosophisches
radio und in der zweiten hälfte der
sendung können leute ja anrufen
das heißt sie können sozusagen bisschen
der bevölkerung den puls fühlen wo die
stehen in ihren wert höher kommen sie
denn das gefühl dass das eine echte
sorge ist in der bevölkerung da draußen
auf den eindruck hat man guckt
eigentlich nicht mehr auf diese
brüchigkeit auf die schwäche also wenn
es eines gibt was ich für mich als
trainer herausstellt und deswegen habe
ich das auch so formuliert dürfen wir so
bleiben wie wir sind dann ist es genau
diese sehnsucht und angenommen zu sein
in dem was nicht perfekt ist das ist für
mich eigentlich ein ganz starkes
leitmotiv aus was viele menschen
momentan bewegt wie kriege ich das für
mich persönlich hin dass ich seiten an
mir akzeptiere die nicht perfekt sind
und wie kriege ich das aber auch an
anderen hin also wie kann ich jemanden
aushalten
wer nicht mehr kann und dem ich immer zu
geben muss am anfang wird in
perfektionisten gesprochen was sie
eigentlich falsch macht und vielleicht
ist das was er falsch macht gar nicht
die innerlichkeit denke ich jetzt
sondern diese unfähigkeit mit den
brüchen umzugehen
das ist dass es gibt ja noch eine dritte
geschichte die ich mit diesem start
verbinde
also ich habe jetzt ausgerechnet das
ende das gebrochene ende mitgebracht was
gekrümmt ist
es ist eben kein gerader stock und wir
menschen sind das auch nicht und
gefühlen ist heute ganz viele wenn sie
an das lebensende denken ja viele
diskussionen darum ob man
süßen tod haben darf man einen anspruch
haben darf auch das wird mit grossem mit
großer power als freiheitsrecht
deklamiert ja mein tod gehört mir naja
natürlich gehört er mir nicht ich mir
nicht ausgesucht weil wir nicht die wahl
hätte würde ich natürlich auch 50 jahren
mit ihnen noch interessante gespräche
führen aber nicht tot in der kiste
liegen und von maden gefräst also wir
können uns sozusagen die sterblichkeit
nicht aussuchen weil es ihn sterbliche
wesen aber den tod keine jungs ein stück
weit heute schon aussuchen
wie wollen sie das sie können gift
nehmen
das kicken sie aber auch keine gute
sache also
da müssen wir genau schauen was ich
daran eigentlich zu kritisieren habe
also ich wäre ja bescheuert wenn ich den
verzweifelten menschen für seine
verzweiflung kritisieren würde dann
würde ich mir auch selber wieder
sprechen dinge verzweiflung sein kann
die bis dahin ganz genau
ganz genau interessant wird es für mich
dann wenn eine gesellschaft anfängt zu
überlegen entwickeln wir eigentlich eine
dienstleistung eine organisierte
dienstleistung für das sterben also
schaffen wir eigentlich ein berufsbild
na ja das tut dass wir jetzt so stark
gesagt weil es geht natürlich um das
kleingedruckte weil es ja ein
[Musik]
kompliziertes gebilde ist wer da wem
hilft ja genau
es geht um den die eigentlich nur
verboten nächsten wieder schweiz also
nur die organisierte suizidbeihilfe in
der schweiz erlaubt und das führt zu
diesen spannungen ja auch im diskurs
unter ethikern deutschland schweiz genau
unterschiedliche positionen gibt wobei
es in beiden ländern liberale das böse
worte gibt wie auch gegner wissen sie
was um das vielleicht ein bisschen
distanziert vergessen wir wie es in der
schweiz ist und wir vergessen wie es in
deutschland ist und wir gucken
stattdessen mal wie ist es eigentlich in
den benelux staaten den niederlanden und
belgien wo ist ja anders als hier oder
in deutschland die aktive sterbehilfe
gibt also tötung auf verlangen ganz
genau da ändert sich das berufsbild des
arztes oder hat sich bereits verändert
und da gehört es eben zum portfolio des
arztes dass er nicht nur lindert und
tröstet und heilt sondern eben auch
tötet und das betrifft und das ist wir
haben über eine positive und negative
freiheit gesprochen
da geht es nicht nur um zwei menschen
die da was machen sondern das ganze
spielt sich auch im rahmen einer ganzen
gesellschaft ab und angenommen wir beide
würden in den niederlanden leben und wir
beide würden jetzt sagen ich habe keinen
bock mehr ich möchte jetzt aktive
sterbehilfe
wir würden das nicht kriegen sie kriegen
das nämlich nur wenn auch die
gesellschaft in gewisser weise jetzt
sage ich mal ein ganz böses wort von
diesem tod profitiert es muss ein schwer
kranker mensch sein es muss eine
aussichtslosigkeit da sein aber der
aktive mensch der würde natürlich dieses
niemals einen anspruch darauf waren also
es gibt ein
es gibt einen sozialen nutzen kalkül was
immer auch bedacht werden muss wenn man
über solche fragen spricht ist das
eigentlich eine gesellschaft die
aufpassen muss dass sie dass sie nicht
davon profitiert wenn ausgerechnet die
schwächsten die dann auch teuer sind
wenn sie sich von den verabschiedeten
jetzt dieses moment dieses profitieren
von einem tod ja man könnte auch sagen
das sind gesellschaften die sehr bemüht
darum sind über das mitleid nachzudenken
und genau zu differenzieren welche
menschen verdienen so großes mitleid was
in diesen mitleiden auch dazu gehört
dass man sie sterben lässt oder ihnen
hilft zu sterben oder sie auch tötet
wenn ich selber nicht tun können weil
sie sich so sehr wünschen aber da müssen
wir genau schauen wer sich das
eigentlich wünscht
und wir haben in deutschland einen
fallen sterbehilfe ev der solche
möglichkeiten bereitstellt und dann eben
mit lebensmüden menschen in die schweiz
reist um diesen assistierten suizid
möglich zu machen und in jedem jahr
veröffentlicht dieser verein ein
jahrbuch in dem die ganzen fälle
dokumentiert sind
und wenn sie das lesen dann sind sie
erschüttert was dafür sterbe wünsche an
die berater herangetragen werden
das ist nämlich nicht die pure
verzweiflung eines menschen immer der an
entschlossen hängt und ein leben voller
qualm führen muss gegen seinen willen
sondern das ist häufiger auch präventiv
die sorge davor dass man sich nicht mehr
helfen kann dass man angehörigen auf den
nerven geht
und wenn ich das lese dann ist das für
mich eigentlich immer eine ohrfeige weil
nämlich eine gesellschaft die die
die sensibel bleiben will
für den umgang mit schwachen das
eigentlich als blamage aufpassen muss
dass menschen obwohl sie noch gar nicht
in einer notlage drin sind bereits sagen
dann gebe ich lieber den löffel ab damit
ich nicht in abhängigkeit von anderen
menschen in einen gerate es gibt in der
schweiz hat sich ganz ganz viele
untersuchungen darüber welche fälle
wirklich zur suizidbeihilfe zugelassen
werden wer diesen wunsch äußert und es
gibt auch ganz viele andere geschichten
deswegen denke ich man muss da
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein mit den geschichten die man erzählt
aber ich glaube es gibt was anderes was
ich ganz interessant finden an dem was
jetzt gerade erzählt haben nämlich das
doch mal wieder so was durch scheint wie
die frage was ist eigentlich das gute
was wir wollen was ist ein gutes leben
für uns und wir wurden aufgerufen so
schwierig ist für andere diese frage zu
beantworten möglicherweise ist ein leben
das sie an einer anderen person noch
durchaus gut finden für diese person
nicht mehr gut und sie können die uns
darüber verständigen
wissen sie ich glaube es ist eher
umgekehrt
ich glaube dass wir bei wo wir gerade
ziemlich aktiv und gesund sind uns viel
schwerer vorstellen können dass das
kranke und schwerst pflegebedürftige
leben auch ein gutes leben sein kann als
umgekehrt wenn man in der situation drin
steckt das ist meine erfahrung von
vorgestern aus der pflegestation dann
gibt es mit den aller beschränkten
möglichkeiten die man überhaupt noch hat
trotzdem eine freude oder jedenfalls ein
dasein wollen leben will mich antwortet
der suizidbeihilfe nicht negieren dass
es sehr viele alte menschen geht
gebrechliche menschen gibt die noch sehr
viel glück und freude im leben empfinden
niemand käme auf die idee zu sagen die
sollen alle mal den löffel abgeben wie
sie es vorher etwas plakativ ausgedrückt
haben ja na gut aber wir müssen doch in
dem wir über solche
über solche möglichkeiten streiten
müssen wir uns das vorstellen wie sich
das gesellschaftlich zusammensetzt
und wenn eine gesellschaft gleich gültig
wird gegenüber diesen akten von 42 ist
ja wir können decke experiment machen
also wir sind jetzt in unseren mittleren
jahren
wir sind aufgewachsen mit einem starken
freiheit bewusstsein mit der vorstellung
autonomie ist das ideal
halten sie das für völlig abwegig dass
man in 30 40 jahren halt diesen süßen
tod als massenphänomen haben wird ja ich
persönlich ja die frage ist auch noch
was ist ein süßer tod ich glaube man
muss schon relativ verzweifelt sein dass
man diese art des sterbens welt aber ich
würde gerne zum schluss noch in eine
andere richtung gehen nämlich in die
frage wie denken wir eigentlich heute
über den tod nach angesichts der
tatsache dass in dieser perfektionierung
welle stecken die sagen ja selber es
gibt so eine optimierungs tränen wir
wollen besser werden
was stört der tod natürlich auch also
die endlichkeit des lebens ist
eigentlich ein stück weit eine
beleidigung für den menschen und sie
würden gerne länger leben
gleichzeitig haben sie auch unendlich
lange leben das will auch keiner was ist
das eigentlich für eine eigenartige
zwickmühle in die wieder geraten ja also
erstmal muss man sagen es gibt natürlich
momentan viele projekte in der
wissenschaft in der bio gerontologie um
das menschliche leben möglichst zu
verlängern und es gibt auch
beeindruckende ergebnisse jetzt nicht
gerade am menschen aber an anderen
kreaturen wie man leben durch
eingriff in deren genetischen natur
verlängern kann also wenn sie jetzt
fadenwürmer nehmen oder mäuse dann ist
das schon was zu machen und die
vorstellung wir könnten unsere
lebensspanne sagen wir mal verdoppeln
die gibt es komischerweise habe ich noch
keinen menschen kennengelernt der sagt
ja heute das will ich ja also es gibt
einen erstmal einen erschrecken eine
intuition die sagt das kann eigentlich
nicht gut sein dass ich 200 kerzen auf
dem geburtstagskuchen habe
vielleicht haben wir uns einfach das
noch nicht vorstellen könnt uns nicht
vorstellen wir beide werden es
wahrscheinlich auch nicht erleben
aber dass man sukzessive menschliches
leben verlängert das ist jedenfalls sehr
denkbar oder so und dann ist die frage
was macht man eigentlich aus diesem
leben und was an welcher stelle wird
denn nun ausgerechnet dieses lebens band
wenn man das zieht und zerrt an welcher
stelle dehnt sich das und dann sagen
natürlich alle dass wenn wir es so schön
wundern wenn er gesehen wie es in der
jugend von mir aus auch noch ein
bisschen mehr goldene mitte aber wir
wollen auf keinen fall dass das
lebensende sich auch noch hinzieht und
was lesen sie daraus ab ja also erstmal
finde ich das interessant dass nun dass
diese beiden themen die wir jetzt
nacheinander besprochen haben sich total
zu widersprechen scheinen also
einerseits wird sehr viel
wissenschaftliche intelligenz und
übrigens auch sehr viel forschungs geld
in projekte gestellt gesteckt das
menschliche leben möglich zu verlängern
andererseits haben wir die tendenz zu
sagen na ja also ausgerechnet das
unangenehme ende das würden wir am
liebsten abschneiden in dem wir das
recht auf den süßen tod einräumen
wie kann das zusammenpasst
ja und das passt meiner meinung nach in
der weise zusammen wie ich das wohin
schon formuliert habe der gemeinsame
nenner ist wir können uns unsere
menschliche existenz eigentlich nur dann
gut vorstellen wenn wir fit und aktiv
sind
entweder sind wir fit oder wir sind tot
und das ist eigentlich fast schon ein
wunderbares schlusswort ich habe mich
sehr gefreut mit einer person zu
sprechen die ich als religiös nicht um
musikalisch bezeichnet das werde ich mal
im kopf behalten und sich gedanken nicht
ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch ich
danke
[Musik]
sport ist natürlich auch sein feld wurde
optimierungs waren offene türen einrennt
mehr dazu aus philosophischer sicht
finden sie auf unserer kultur plattform
nächste woche führen wie hier ein
gespräch mit einem hohen gast
bundesrätin simonetta sommaruga nimmt
stellung zu ihrer haltung zu den
verdienen kindern und anderen
jugendlichen opfern staatliche
zwangsmaßnahmen und jetzt achtung luxus
und achtung generalität ihre sitzmöbel
wurden zu design ikonen ein filmporträt
to ray und charles eames den designer
paar des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
[Musik]